hallo freuen und herzlich willkommen
hier zu einem kleinen video am montag
und zwar ist das nur so ein kleiner
updater was gerade bei mir ab geht ihr
denkt ich wahrscheinlich etwas über dem
ab gehen die letzten tage kam doch immer
videos und auch die nächsten tage werden
immer noch mal videos kommen aber ich
bin gerade nicht dort irgendwo in
deutschland sondern in new york
eventuell sollte man die kürzung
ich bin gerade in new york und zwar
könnte man sagen kann da bin ich
losgeflogen am 14
das ist der sonntag das heißt das war
gestern und ich bin wegen der
zeitverschiebung auch gestern am sonntag
schon nachmittags in new york angekommen
da werdet ihr eventueller instagram so
ein paar bilder gesehen haben da ich
jetzt noch nicht weiß welche bilder ich
bei instagram hochladen werden oder bei
snap chat posten werde zeige ich euch
hier einfach mal dass sich
beispielsweise so eins machen werde
oder ich werde so eins machen und dann
werde ich da sein scheine also hier am
am sonntag bin ich gestern in new york
angekommen dann bin ich mit den 15 16 17
18 19 komplette new york und hier am
zwanzigsten fliege ich dann zurück und
bin dann irgendwann zwanzigster ganz
früh morgens wieder deutschland das
jetzt muss ein kleines video euch das zu
sagen dass ich da in der zeit weg bilden
bzw jetzt ab heute auch noch weiter in
new york bin
das heißt wenn irgend etwas nicht
klappen sollte was videos angeht oder
irgendwelche post kommen zu früher wo
das video noch gar nicht online ist und
alles mögliche es tut mir leid
dann habe ich nicht ganz genau geschafft
alles perfekt vorzug zieren sonst würde
ich euch mit diesem video auch nur noch
sagen dass ich bei instagram laser luca
heiße und bei snap chat auch laser luca
das heißt wenn ihr bock habt auf
irgendwelche bilder aus new york oder
wenn ich dort auf dem empire state
building stehe und beispielsweise mit
snapshot 111 mache und ihn durch die
streets of the big apple auf
dann könnt ihr mich dort gerne
bei den beiden netzwerken ich habe mir
extra über die telekom so einen
komischen passt geholt das sich im
ausland surfen kann nein das ist kein
produkt placement für die telekom das
habe ich alles selbst bezahlt freunde so
ein bisschen ab ich dass man
mittlerweile bei jeder marke die man
erwähnt dazu sagen muss dass man dafür
kein geld bekommt es ist sonst hoffe ich
dass die videos bisher pünktlich
bekommen sondern auch in den nächsten
tagen beziehungsweise in der nächsten
woche beziehungsweise anteil pünktlich
kommen werden da ich am 20 noch nach
berlin weiterfliegen und ganz viele
verschiedene tricks der zahl ich hoffe
einfach dass ich das ganze packen werde
ich hoffe die videos kommen passend und
ich hoffe auch dass euch dieses video
heute montag falls euch das nicht reicht
heute als video habe ich hier noch ein
video was ich euch zeigen kann wo ich am
14 februar irgendwie ein zaubertrick
gemacht habe oh mein gott wer das nur
gemacht aber ich sage euch sogar noch
ein video wohl mein badezimmer so ein
kleines tierchen ist dann abgehauen und
ich hab den seitdem nie wieder gesehen
seitdem habe ich jetzt man so ein
kleines silberfischchen als haustier hat
ja sonst war's das für heute freunde tut
mir leid dass ich für heute nicht mehr
habe ich habe einfach gedacht schon
wieder zu machen ich bin in new york und
das tut mir leid falls videos nicht
wirklich kommen aber jetzt habt ihr noch
einen zaubertrick gesehen also und zu
meinem haustier und also zusammengefasst
hoffe ich dass die videos pünktlich
kommen in den nächsten tagen und wenn
ihr bock auf tägliche updates haben was
bei mir geht wie es in new york läuft
dann auf instagram und snap chat folgen
sonst wenn euch das video trotzdem
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und wir sehen uns dann
in den sozialen netzwerken wieder oder
irgendwie dem morgen wo ich euch ein
command vorstellen